[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on the 12th of July I'm
James Hill The Spectators politics
correspondent and your host for this
week's episode
coming up on the show
can the conservatives really stop the
boats via the illegal migration bill as
MPS and lowers fight over the flagship
peace legislation I'll be speaking the
two side of the argument Tom Hunt MP and
Tim fahren for the live devs will AI be
the death of us all that's what Eliza
yakowski believes former number 10
advisor James Phillips interviewed him
the magazine this week we'll show
Clipper the discussion on the show
The Spectators political editor Katie
balls takes a look at Labor's
relationship with the trade unions in
this week's column candy whenever the
likes of Mick Lynch and others Katie and
Stephen Bush join me on the show
for the cover piece this week author and
contributor Louise Perry looks at
Britain's dangerous addiction to plastic
surgery and how much social media is
driving the trend I was speaking to her
later finally Britain's Dune love to
gossip and know more so when it's about
a public figure like Philip Schofield or
George Osborne historian Alice loxton
has written about the history of Gossip
in Britain and why we love it so much
she joins me on the show
before we get going why not subscribe to
The Spectator if you subscribe today
you'll not only get your first month
free but after your trial you'll pay
just one pound a week for full access to
our website and app or two pounds a week
if you want the print magazine too claim
this great offer go to spectator.com
best
and if you enjoyed spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss another episode
first up in Westminster this week the
Lords have been worried with MPS of the
illegal migration Bill some see it as
essential to stop the votes crossing the
channel but the Bill's critics believe
it criminalizes some of the most
vulnerable people in the world well
joining me now are two people from
either side of that debate Tom Hunt
considered MP for Ipswich and Tim fahren
the libdo MP and author of a monkey
business like Christians should get
involved in politics
Tim you tweeted yesterday that this
legislation was the worst piece you've
seen in 18 and a bit years as an MP tell
us why
uh because it's based on loads of bogus
information I think it's entirely
legitimate to have a different point of
view
um the majority of things I've had to
vote on there's about 18 and a half
years including many when I was actually
in on the government side are things I
didn't agree with but I think the the
legislation that is being pinged and
pong between the two houses of
Parliament at the moment is based on all
sorts of assumptions that are false
um the uh essential understanding that
you know we are in a worse position than
anywhere else that people are heading
straight for the United Kingdom and uh
and yet the reality is 70 of people who
flee
um their home country as refugees stay
in the next door country an Ever
decreasing fraction of people uh move
further and further away a small
minority come to Europe a very small
minority come to the United Kingdom and
many of those by the way uh who come
over the channel to the UK
um will do so and we'll not be refugees
it's a minority the government's own
figures show it's a minority of about
one in five but we'll never know that if
we don't process them so having a policy
a piece of legislation that he
essentially says we're going to assume
everybody is bogus bracket when our own
figures know that 80 aren't and
therefore break all sorts of
international understandings in the
process it's essentially tackling one
small symptom of a colossal Global
problem and doing it badly on the basis
of wrong information so it's not just a
decision I disagree with most of them
are those it's a decision I can't have
any respect for because it's based on a
total bogus misunderstanding or rather I
don't think the government are
misunderstanding it at all they know
these facts and figures and they choose
to do what they're doing because they
think it has some political benefit for
them so it's very hard to respect
um those behind it Tom what's all your
response to that I mean there are some
claims I mean Tim made them yesterday in
his speech in the comments was that
perhaps you know there's been sort of
over to an extent my ministers what's
your reaction to all of that you know I
was I'm glad to support the bill happy
to support the bill
um you know very happy to vote against
you know 18 laws amendments yesterday
um I think it's needed I think this is a
great concern to my constituents uh they
want us to have control of our borders I
think there's a majority of people in
this country you want us to have control
of his borders and I think to do that we
need to have a deterrent
um and I think the important point is
you know these are overwhelmingly seem
to be single men who can afford to pay
people Smugglers who have come through
multiple safe European countries uh
before they've illegally entered our
country we've got to have a robust
approach I think this bill does that I'm
happy to support it and to me the point
of the speech yesterday which was that
you know if every country starts doing
this you know in terms of uh closing
down these legal routes I mean that
could cause the whole collapse of the
system is that not a real issue
particularly when Britain won some of
the figures is not taking as many as say
Germany for instance yeah I mean I I'd
also say actually talking about Germany
that actually is acceptance rate for
refugees is actually quite a bit lower
than it is in the UK when it comes to
claims it's quite interesting point but
I tell you where I've just been I've
just been with um iom talking about the
rohingya refugee situation I've been to
rohingy cap three times myself and and
and people are speaking to told me that
um some other other countries us uh
Canada uh nothing now even Australia and
New Zealand will be taking uh refugees
from from England refugee camps so that
I can see what's happening globally I'm
very aware that we have a GT to be
generous towards genuine refugees uh
fleeing persecution and I'm Not For a
Moment saying that I don't want us to be
generous but we have to have a but we
have to have a managed way of doing it
we've got to have a controlled we've got
to have a system of doing it and I think
if we if we have control of it and we
have a system has integrity at its heart
I think the British public will get
behind it because they are compassionate
but what they don't want to see is tens
of thousands of people jumping the queue
and arriving here illegally which is
what has been happening I mean Tim you
proposed uh having more safe and legal
routes to do this I mean is that really
the case I mean surely critics of that
will just say we're rewarding criminal
Behavior effectively
well no you bypass criminal Behavior it
says if for example when I did a visit
with a conservative and labor MPS to
Calais last year we met one of the
conservative MPS for Calais
um for whom obviously it's a huge
problem for him locally but he was
thinking about the situation Beyond his
community as well
in France there's a there's quite an
appetite amongst you know sensible
politicians of all different political
flavors for allowing people to apply for
asylum in the United Kingdom from a
place in France so you don't need to
cross the channel to do so and here's
the thing really the the fact is that a
real deterrent would be if we had a
system that worked in the end what this
really is all about is the pictures of
people crossing by boats but also the
awareness there's 177 000 people at the
last count in temporary accommodations
of which are hotels around the country
that's because the government's not
managing the situation now I don't know
the situation or the details of uh what
happened to the many more refugees that
there are in Germany than there are in
the UK and if there's a lower Grant rate
maybe it's because they actually process
their refugees whereas we don't process
ours those that we do process by the way
turn out 80 to be actual refugees and
one of the problems is that we you know
jumping the queue I hear the point and
but the simple reality is any Refugee
who runs away is in a sense jumping the
queue they are seeking to kind of get a
better life and to run away from war and
persecution and all the rest of it 99 99
government figures of Eritrean refugees
people who come to the United Kingdom by
whatever means normally buy votes turn
out to be genuine refugees we know
anything about Eritrea that would not
surprise you however there is not a
single safe route there is no
resettlement program there is nothing
equivalent to Ukraine Afghanistan Syria
or Hong Kong which by the way are the
only places you can legally come from
now as a result of this bill so what are
we saying to those people
um who are victims of Africa Kim Jong-un
basically similar kind of situation
there we're saying we will not help you
and so we've got to have a system which
allows us to provide Sanctuary for those
who desperately need it and not play up
nonsense that makes out that somehow
Britain is a wash if you put Britain
back into the EU for League table
purposes per capita we're 22nd at 28 in
terms of the number of people we take um
as Asylum Seekers I I think in in many
respects I think to those who
um you know don't feel as though as a
country we've taken enough refugees I
think it would be very legitimate for
them to say look we should take more and
we should
um we should have more safe and evil
roots and this is sort of what the cap
would be roughly because I'm assuming
we'd be a cat I can't imagine anyone who
really would be young cat
um but but at the same time realize that
we we can't have a situation where we
have tens of thousands people turning up
illegally but these are dangerous
Crossing so we must deter But ultimately
when we talk about safe and legal routes
um I labor for example talk about seven
Eagle Roots they talk about they need to
be a capital and say what the cap should
be whatever it should be but my view is
if you could apply into if you could
apply for Asylum
um in the UK from another country I
think quite quickly that cap would be
reached quite quickly would be reached
um and then we could be back at square
what with people who you know who who
think they're SMGs but the Cap's been
reached for that year save as an annual
cap who will then continue to make
um dangerous Crossings across the
channel there's a reality to the
situation which is we have potentially
um
tens of millions of even across across
the world he could potentially claim to
be Refugee or get Revenue status we
can't take all of them
we're a small item therefore we we do
need to have a cap and and if we have a
cap if there is a cap then we have to
think about how we prioritize
and I just happen to think
uh that we've so for example some of the
rohingya refugees I've met three times
mainly women and children perhaps
slightly higher up that priority list
than mainly single men who come through
multiple safe European countries
um and actually the the very refugees
that I met don't have the opportunity to
shop between different safe European
countries about where I want to go and
actually
seeking a better life is different from
fleeing persecution
yeah but isn't one of the issues that
this legislation is that it's so black
and white in terms of the exemptions it
puts down that those kind of individual
you know excrucially of those cases
where you might have a heart you know
release a personal story about someone
who's overcome you know such adversary
adversity and face terrible things that
we can't even think of they're going to
sort of all those kind of opt-outs are
going to be taken out by this bill and
that's their real problem here but I
think it's a really important thing you
know if you are in a desperate situation
involved fleeing persecution then
apply for asylum in your first safe
country
you know it's important to realize that
all of these individuals have been in
front which is safe where they could
Acclaim this island before they got to
France presumably we were in for many
other and safe European countries many
of them are coming to the UK not
necessarily because they want to be safe
because they're safe in France but
they're coming to the UK for perhaps for
other reason which is why I probably
encourage them to look at our Point
space in the Greek immigration system
and come here legally it's not break our
immigration Tim what's your response to
that then I mean I'm surely as Tom said
I mean the argument put forward by
conservative MPS is that why aren't they
just stay in the first safe country
oh nearly three calls them do 70 to do
um so but are we to say that you know
Lebanon for example has got to take
absolutely everybody a hundred percent
of people gonna stay next door come off
it so the reality is first of all most
people do exactly that secondly there is
on the United Nations convention you are
not obliged to stop at the safe for a
safe place for perfectly good reasons a
because it would mean some country would
bear and even more unfair burden than is
currently the case and secondly people
often have good reason to be somewhere
else so you might when I meet people who
are refugees who are heading towards the
United Kingdom it's because they're ex
British colonies very often and see as
they as the motherland they see or or
they have family relations uh here and
and other connections but the thing is
this so first of all
um most people do stay in the next door
country
secondly they don't have to under U.N
law and we should be grateful for that
and then thirdly there is a trickling
down if you like as you as people
predominantly for coming from the whole
of Africa find their way onto Mainland
Europe it's a minority that do and
people stop along the way so is France a
safe country yes it is and the massive
majority of people who go to France stay
in France and and France could easily
say right Britain said we're not taking
people from France they can all clear
off back to France they'll come in the
first place we'll not even process them
we'll even look at where they are or not
refugees and France could say right same
to Italy same to Spain they're safe
countries too and then what have you got
breakdown of the International System so
you've got one of two things well
actually you know both of two things
will happen one is Britain becomes more
of a pariah internationally it becomes
less significant less influential seem
as a bad team player and secondly at the
same time you'll have some people who
will copy us so you have a combination
of Britain being further reduced in its
standing and Effectiveness and influence
in the world and secondly you'll have to
break down the existing pretty tenuous
system that already exists so I just
think it's incredibly foolish and based
upon all sorts of false premises and by
the way there's no scheme to another
rohingus coming here either in the end a
competent government would assess those
people who arrive here and would send
back the ones that are not refugees and
you only know that if you assess them by
the way people crossing on boats is a
thing we really don't want but one thing
people have got to understand this is
what's so frustrating and it shows such
a lack of being basic Research into
what's going on out there if you fled
from Sudan for example and you have
worked your way through
Libya which is an appalling place is a
reminder that no situation is ever so
bad you can't make it worse you know the
Gaddafi's time in Libya almost seems
like a dream compared to what it is like
there now it is a hell hole for people
passing through it so you have somehow
got through Libya you have crossed the
Mediterranean on a flimsy vote you've
had whatever you've had through Europe
as you've headed towards family or the
mother country in the UK I'm afraid a
few miles on a boat over the channel
which seems terrifying to you and me
it's not a lot compared to the horror
that they have been through already
which is why we should be looking at
providing safe routes much further down
the line not even in France further back
I'm just I'm just really I'm really
interested by this so I'm just imagining
that me me and Tim are putting in the
room for a day we are the government me
and Tim and we have to come up with a
solution to this to this issue uh I I
think that um you know I do have I am
compassionate towards one US wanting to
help refugees I'm I'm
okay we both want to stop Small Boat
Crossings Tim says a way to do that is
to have a more safe and legal Roots but
I want to understand more how this would
work so what I would mean in practice is
you could claim for a Asylum for Refugee
status in the UK from
from from anywhere across the world
presumably and I'd also want to know
from Tim
roughly what sort of cap would he be
looking at would it be uncapped would it
be capped on an annual level what did
what do you think a generous Refugee cap
would look like
well the government doesn't know and
there would be no cap from the
government's perspective either because
in the end uh what is being proposed is
to effectively take anybody who arrives
here irregularly
um and because he's not illegal and
under international law is irregular
um anybody who arrives here irregularly
would eventually be taken to Rwanda
that's an uncapped number so the
government I have an uh the government
have an uncapped number of Asylum
Seekers that the UK taxpayer will pay
for through the Rwanda system okay so I
what I think and you won't get it you
know that what I think
Tim is therefore saying is that anyone
if they believe that they're a refugee
should be able to and free to apply to
be get Refugee status in the UK from
wherever they are in the world and they
shouldn't be a cap and potentially if
that means that we have
um over a million applications that are
successful
but a million extra refugees we take
that year as the UK is there a point
where you'd introduce a capital
so there is no well so there's no cap on
your proposal so the United Kingdom
could very easily take a million people
under the illegal immigration bill that
with the United Kingdom government and
the United Kingdom taxpayer is
responsible for
um to Warehouse in the United Kingdom
because you'll have to do that because
there's no way you're going to get the
numbers of people you think you are to
Rwanda just um logistically and but the
place we start so this glorious
Coalition of you and me in government
dealing with this Tom the first thing we
do is admit it's an awful lot harder and
a lot more difficult and be an awful lot
more grown up about it than the guru and
his current government is being there is
not an easy answer and it does involve
much better policing of our Shores or
more importantly of the French Shores
working with them to make sure these
don't come across they're in line mine
up until about well up until really the
pandemic a little bit beforehand there
wasn't a huge small boat Crossing uh
industry for two or three reasons one is
there wasn't such good policing of the
channel tunnel and people were coming
that way and then secondly once that
unsafe route was closed up people found
other unsafe routes to manage to come
across and so the the reality is that
we're dealing with a demand that is out
there and how do you do it in a in a
manageable and mature way and that's why
being part of the International
Community and behaving like it is the
way you police the numbers but the idea
that there's going to be a million
people coming when we already take only
a quarter of what Germany takes only
seven percent of all of the eu's
um refugees is a reminder that this is a
problem but it's not the kind of
Emergency the United Kingdom government
is making out that it is and so my
accusation really is the government
knows this and rather than being mature
about the problem and acknowledging that
is a difficult problem with tough
solutions that involved more than one
solution is going for something
simplistic that won't work and threatens
Britain's status around the world and is
also inhumane
next do we know the full dangers of
artificial intelligence computer
scientist elieza yukowski has a far more
Bleak view than some of his peers he
believes AI could be the end of mankind
but is he right we recorded an exclusive
interview for The Spectator magazine
between former number 10 advisor James
Phillips early Isa udcasi to discuss you
can watch a clip of it now below
what what is it necessarily that makes
super intelligence so scary to you
because in the time letter you said that
your expectation and that of many others
and I know many of these people
um it's definitely true think that as
soon as you get a sort of Highly super
intelligent organism intelligence
um Humanity will will be wiped out but
for some people that's a big jump what's
what have you found is like the best way
of explaining to people why why you have
that belief and how that would actually
happen
so different people get stuck at
different points along the way
um the first thing I would say is that
it's not that anything smarter than us
must in principle theoretical absolute
law like conservation of energy
um destroy us all
there would be possible super
intelligences that didn't destroy us all
we don't know how to build that
where
extremely early
in scientific terms and like terms of
the progress of a scientific field when
it comes to understanding and shaping uh
even the versions of AI that we have now
to say nothing of something smarter than
us
and if we had like an unlimited time to
work on this if we had 50 years 100
years to work on this if we got an
unlimited number of tries if we could
build one and and the whoops that didn't
work build another one whoops that
didn't work
um I think it would probably in some
sense might even just be an or something
of an ordinary scientific challenge if
you got an unlimited number of tries
um the part that I'm worried about is
that if you make have a little oopsie
with something that is much smarter than
you everyone dies
rather than you getting to go back and
try again
uh I could talk specifically about the
sheer opacity of these systems the
degree to which
um they're more grown than built we have
no idea what goes on in there
I could talk about the foreseeable
difficulties given the way that we grow
them of getting them to internally
launch particular things rather than
just sort of exhibiting temporary
outward behaviors
um
I could talk about the reason to expect
that if you go up something much smarter
than you you lose even if it starts out
with it spraying on a computer somewhere
the same way that your mind is stuck
inside a little Cavern in your skull
um it starts you know if it starts out
connected to the internet how it
bootstraps from there
what sort of more powerful Technologies
are ones which we ourselves understand
well enough to guess that's something
much smarter than us could build them
quickly
um
that things with
random desires that don't specifically
care about you that don't specifically
care about safety at life if they got
very very powerful they don't want to
kill you but they do other things that
kill you as a side effect
or they calculate that they can get more
of the Galaxy for themselves if they
prevent you from building any
competitors
um there's a there's a number of points
here and different people tend to think
that different ones are the obvious
important point that they want to see
addressed immediately and the other ones
are just distractions they don't know
why you're talking about so like I mean
one of the one of the issues you have in
thinking about this is you know if I was
to play Gary Casper over chess um I
could be very confident here baby but I
wouldn't have any idea ahead of time how
he would do it it's sort of similar we
can't really imagine what a super
intelligence um would be like
um I think like
in in terms of
the question that comes up a lot is you
know why why would it want to do this
and you know from reading what you've
written
um you know I I know in some sense
that's kind of that question might be
looking at it from the wrong perspective
and that it doesn't want to kill you
which just incidentally does it so would
you mind like giving an example of how
something like that would happen
um well if it's much much smarter than
you if it can bootstrap to the point of
self-replicating factories
um and it wants to do anything that
requires it to do a lot of computation
then
it if it's you know you can build lots
and lots of fusion plants
self-replicating Machinery that builds
fusion power plants to run your
computers
and if you build enough of those you are
start to be limited by heat dissipation
before you run out of hydrogen in the
oceans diffuse
so even if it doesn't specifically go
out of its way to kill you you might die
when the oceans boil off and Earth's
surface gets too hot to live on because
of the amount of power that's being
generated
now it could go out of its way to save
you if it wanted to do that but it's not
likely to
well we don't have the technology we
don't know how to make it want to save
us so that's like the the critical point
of
um we don't know how to align a machine
with what what human values are however
you define human values and are progress
in making these things more capable at
achieving a task that we've set it is
going much faster than our ability to
get it to do it in a way that we would
like so the classic example is the
paperclip maximizer where now you ask it
to produce as many paper clips as
possible and pretty soon it's killed
everyone and turned the whole world into
paid Clips kind of right of thinking
that's actually a distorted story The
the original version is that you just
completely lose control of the utility
Fellowship you build a thing you you try
to shape its preferences you fail the
preferences end up not literally like
random roll of a dice but from your
perspective they're pretty random
and then it
the part of its utility function the
things that satisfied that scales the
fastest
or like or that is like most efficient
to satisfy
um at scale
turns out to be maximized by
configurations of matter that are shaped
by tiny molecular paper clips
is the original example and Nick Bostrom
then simplified it to a paperclip
Factory but I think this is actually
like a poor simplification for a couple
of reasons one of which is that the
whole point from my perspective is that
you can't make it want paperless paper
clips are something that it ends up
wanting by accident
problem number two what kills you isn't
going to be an AI that was deployed to a
factory it's going to be you know like
Frontier thing in the research lab that
probably hasn't been deployed to anyone
at all
so you have you you have
how how where would you put your
confidence level on the
on the sort of hypothesis that you put
forward in the time article that
everyone dies are you sort of at the 90
likelihood or is it even a meaningful
question because you you seem quite
confident about about your projection
that this is this this needs to all be
shot down because otherwise we will die
I mean how would you define your and how
has that changed over time
I I mean I would say that if we go ahead
and build a super intelligence and
anything remotely like the current
technology anything current remotely
like the current social situation where
you know you you've got like the heads
of of major AI Labs denying that any
problem could possibly exist they don't
deny that you can build super
intelligence they deny that it could
possibly reasonably go wrong
like that is actually the line they are
putting forth right now
and if if we just like plunger had
anything like the current state the
probability that we die is yes the
probability is I haven't seen anything
as weird as us surviving happening often
enough
for for me to like put it to be able to
calibrate my own probabilities I have to
be like very very wrong about something
in a direction that makes the problem
easier rather than harder and I don't
know how you're supposed to put a
probability on
but you know I would say it's more than
like 99 than 90 percent
that if we just like keep going on a
straight line will I mean in the early
days
um when you read statements from Shane
leg and and Sam Altman and others they
they were much more clear openly that
they were trying to build machines that
could do anything a human can do that
was their sort of the AGI lion and yet
seems like that's gone quieter over the
last couple of years and when I speak to
sort of seeing a government science
advisors they don't seem to quite get
what the end goal of places like open Ai
and deepmind
um is which is I don't know if that's
deliberate by them or if that's just the
way that the media is reporting it but
it seems that their end goal hasn't
hasn't filtered through
um to the public and my own experiences
of this is in talking to the to the to
you know people who aren't who aren't AI
researchers is people find that idea
um quite horrifying and I think it
reflects something that I think you've
said that when chat GPT
um came out more and more people saying
to you that you know why are we doing
this and that's been very much the the
um the message that it picks up as well
yeah I have a similar impression my
impression is well first of all to be
clear like as far as I know Shane Legg
has not
changed his tune publicly and said that
there's no danger
so like like shame like is one of the
people who is relatively more informed
and you know he's constrained by being a
co-founder of deepmind but he hasn't
gone around telling people oh no yeah
you know I wasn't suggesting that
um yeah
yeah yeah and and the other thing is
like you know back in those days you
could be like yeah sure we're like going
to build something smarter than human
and people and Chachi PT didn't exist
yet so people didn't take that seriously
and it was just like oh cool yeah like
you go you
and then AI came along that could
actually talk to people and people were
like wait you're doing what but you know
the the old tweets already exist and to
some extent the media has no memory so
they're getting away with it
um and also like I'm not sure that I
would say that some of the people saying
these things really believed Their Own
Line themselves
like it was always apparent to me that
you'd get to Super intelligence
eventually if you just kept pushing
and for me that was just like a part of
the real world like any other part of
the real world
um and you know I was like and as soon
as I realized that aligning AI was going
to be a problem at all that they weren't
just going to automatically end up nice
after like poking out the problem for a
while you know getting into the
technical details realized nope they're
not now going to be nice which is kind
of the why I started alkaliating
um
I was like whoa like major planetary
emergency coming up in an unknown number
of years
and some people 20 years will go like no
no it's going to be like 50 years out
and that's somehow fine
and
other people were like yeah we're gonna
let go out and build super intelligence
but did they really believe it deep down
to me it seems that if you really
believe that deep down you might be you
know kind of kind of worried about
whether or not you could pull it off
without killing literally everyone
um so I don't know to what extent the
people who early on were like
confidently like thrusting out their
chest and being like yeah we're going to
build super intelligence light I'm not
sure to what extent they were
able to have models where what they were
saying was real so like this is this
there's a form of super intelligence
where it exists and it's almost by
definition able to you know
do the terrible things which would end
the world
um I guess like there's also a lot of
potential benefit from Ai and you know
you've you've mentioned in your time
article for example that there could be
exemptions for say medical research AIS
um now I think like
what do you have do you have a view like
go ahead well I I to just say clearly
that I'm not that's not because medical
research is important on par with human
extinction but because the medical
research line of things what you need to
augment human intelligence and get us
out of the terrible situation we're in
like I wasn't saying I wasn't trading
off Extinction risk against medical
benefits I was foreseeing that we needed
the biotech so what's what how would you
describe where the the line is or is
there a line that you could draw that
that people should be thinking about
this this kind of AI development is okay
this is good
um whereas this side is bad or you of
the view that as these things get more
and more capable they will inherently
develop goal-seeking behavior that
inherently begin trying to maximize some
function that we don't we don't
think will end up with aligned Behavior
I think if you push anything far enough
especially on anything remotely like the
current paradigms
like if you make it capable enough the
way it gets that capable is by starting
to be General
and at the same sort of point where it
starts to be General it will start to
have its own internal preferences
because that is how you get to be
General
you don't
become creative and able to solve lots
and lots of problems without something
inside you that organizes your problem
solving and that thing is like a
preference any goal and it's not built
in explicitly it's just something that's
sought out by the process that we use to
grow these things to be more and more
capable
um with that said I don't know exactly
how far you can push
it's possible that you so like right now
uh Alpha fold two is like the world's
leading AI when it comes to predicting
how proteins fold up
and as far as I know they like didn't
have to get anywhere near generality in
order to pull that off successfully
so you can probably push Alpha fold even
further you might even be able to have
it start designing proteins that have
particular chemical properties
might be able to get it to try to decode
biological systems
and you would want to be on the lookout
for science that it was starting to
generalize and then you would pull back
but as long as you are building a narrow
AI That's all you can solve your calls
with the narrow AI not not a general AI
that you try to only get to think about
one kind of problem but something that
was just like narrow from the start and
never saw any signs of generalizing
um my guess is that you're safe
you know just a wild guess not based on
any clear informed scientific theory
just my personal guess
Next Live party from all the century has
had close ties to the Trade union
movement but as these have become to
deteriorate between kirstama and the
union leaders what will be their role in
the future of Labor and pledgingly the
next government joining me to discuss
are Katie balls and Stephen Bush of the
financial times
Katie what is kirstama's relationship
with trade unions like so he's not a
natural trade unionist he of course is a
career lawyer who then moved into
politics and therefore identity is anti
the trade unions but we're in a very
different world than we think back to
the Jeremy corbyn era at that point
um you often saw of course Len mcclasky
who was at the time at the general
secretary unite he was one of the four
M's along with Seamus Milne
um Andrew Murray and Carrie Murphy and
they've formed the quad and were often
blamed being Jerry Corbin's brain
whether it was uh you know lackluster
support for staying in the EU
um in the view of Labor MPS or just
general corbyn policies and and
therefore it felt as though you know it
was very key in making lots of decisions
I think under Chris Dharma and so it's
actually been an active effort as part
of the rebranding of the labor party to
show that they are willing to stand up
to the unions
um I I think had an interesting
conversation with Phillips in the shadow
education secretary a few months ago and
when she was talking about being
hackered at the NAU conference the
National Education Union and this was
about
um of stead and the fact that unlike
Jeremy corbyn who would abolish it his
son would keep it they'd use a very
popular word Arbor from and to have sort
of the due to it and it was always she
almost get a sense when you talk to
somebody's Shadow cabinet members is
almost a bad honor if the unions are a
bit unhappy of what they're doing
because they're showing their willing to
take company
um them on so we're in a different world
but it's different than saying that kids
drama's anti-union and I think you know
if we you have a situation where leaders
officer Ryland Union stayed Affiliated
those are currently but there's
definitely a determination to show
they're not as dependent and also it's
partly because they they aren't as
dependent as they used to be I would
love to go to private donations coming
in and feeding that Gap where the unions
were the main funder and then Stephen
you know he's talking about sort of
publicly and show people that was
treating are very happy to go out there
and criticize the BMA but privately do
they retain much influence in the making
a layer policy well the crucial thing to
remember about both the trade unions
you've just named the BMA and the Neu
isn't they are not affiliated trade
unions right and basically if you are
the leader of the labor party you can't
you know whether you're Jeremy corbyn or
Tony Blair or Hugh Gates or Harold
Wilson or kirst armor you cannot
effectively run the party if you do not
have basically at least two of the big
Affiliated trade unions willing to
either deliver a few um pretty
consistently or deliver fee on a
transactional basis and broadly speaking
um one of the re one of Jeremy Corwin's
big difficulties is that
um
his only way of getting stuff done was
the axis Souls he's supporting the
grassroot and unite the Trade union
which meant broadly speaking
he didn't he wasn't you know you're most
powerful at a labor leader where you can
do a deal with one trade Union One Week
another Trade union the next week etc
etc kirst armor isn't quite in that
position but he has slightly more
flexibility whereas on everything from
yeah the EU obviously being the most
politically fought thing in the last
Parliament but something I imagine most
viewers have forgotten which is the uh
vote on Heathrow expansion broadly
speaking that position on Heathrow was
not one that I would say anyone who was
close to the ear of Jeremy corbyn really
wanted but unite represents a lot of
members at Heathrow and so they got what
they wanted and so the labor leadership
is still yeah there's a reason why we're
streating feels much more able to talk
about reforming GP standing up to the
BMA than he does about nurses because
nurses are partially represented by
Unison and Unison are an Affiliated
Trade union and so it's not just uh you
know kisama of course okay it's in your
column this week you write about Rachel
Reed's relationships with the Union tell
us about that yeah so I think as Steve
mentions ultimately we separate the
unions when we talk other from the
non-affiliated and Affiliated so the
three most important unions are unite uh
who this week had a vote
um about potentially disaffiliating it's
not the first time they've done this so
there's some groans
um from the labor party and that did not
succeed overwhelmingly they voted in
favor but you had the lead of putting
the generals actually put in case
someone on notice that they had to
listen more to them and then you have
Unison uh which is to Stephen says
looking after a lot care workers nurses
and then you have GMB which is a you
know lots of the industrial
um sectors now Rachel Reeves has I think
managed to annoy quite a lot of the
unions including some of the affiliated
with her comments recently about
independent pay review bodies and how
she would not necessarily she would not
pre-commit to accepting the
recommendations of independent pay
review bodies when it comes to public
sector pay Rises and that I think I'm
surprisingly got short shift from the
Unions that's something they want
but other than that I think when you
look at those free big unions United is
probably the most hostile the free
towards the labor leadership and of
course by being Affiliated it's not just
money in the party get your skin votes
um NEC meetings before the election on
the manifesto and then you have probably
Unison is the most supportive of the
kirstama leadership
um The First beginning to back his armor
and the labor leadership contest and
then summer in the middle is GMB and I
think partly because
um of the leanings of the other two it's
definitely seen as probably the most
influential and that's you know that
rich Reeves enjoys a good relationship
with the leader Gary Smith and Jimmy's a
really interesting Union isn't it
Stephen in light of what's been going
with the green New Deal within labor
yeah because I mean yeah the B does
stand for Boilermakers right so we are
talking about a union which is both on
the front line of lots of the stuff and
they want to do about insulation you
know heat pumps Etc all of that kind of
stuff but is also at the front line of
the type of jobs that we would expect
the green transition to get rid of and
precisely for the reasons sort of Katie
says right because they are the swing
the available swing mode right as door
and Unison are going to back uh Kierst
armor pretty much no matter what your
knight are going to oppose them on many
many things uh so the GMB has set
themselves up very well and that yeah
there was a lot a lot of noise recently
about um Labor's policy on oil and gas
some people talking about how it was
because the Scottish slave party was
worried about the SNP well no one in the
legal party thinks they're going to win
back the Aberdeen seats right those
that's the heart of Scottish nationalism
now what that is really about is the GMB
going uh excuse me if you want to
continue
um dominating the Parliamentary
selections as the storm rights are if
you want to continue getting your
business passed on the floor for the
labor Party Conference without
unedifying floor fights on national TV
which obviously they did very
successfully in recent conferences yo
what have you done for us lately and
that I think is going to be a big
tension right because the late party's
big argument is well we wouldn't have to
do any of this difficult stuff on on tax
Rises because we have a growth strategy
what is their gross statute actually is
their climate strategy well who is the
biggest winner from some of their
climate strategy members of the GMB who
is The Biggest Loser from some of their
climate sanctity members of the DMV and
uh Katie you know Stephen has previously
written about some of the sort of policy
wins which you just can expect perhaps
in government tell us about some of
those what are they likely to see so I
think the the big the biggest current
offerings in unions is something uh that
we've heard from Angela Rayner and
obviously lots of different job titles
at the moment um but the labor reshuffle
that could be slimmed down shortly but
she and when we talk about well uh
kirstama is you know trade genius well
his Deputy definitely is you know she
used to work at Unison and I think
therefore the charter of workers rights
that she set at previously something
which uh you can expect the labor
government to bring in the first 100
days in terms of bringing in changes to
workers rights is something which I
think is is seen as all the units were
welcome then I think you so so that's
like part and parcel and then I think
you get to what are the other areas and
that's when you get back to the green
debate and GMB I think are playing a
really influential voice in this I think
you have I have a quote in the piece uh
by uh you know an anonymous quote but
someone in number 10 I was speaking to
so this is a conservative thing
Gary Smith this is the Scottish Union
Leader Jim Beasley Gary is a good guy
I'm not sure that's what Gary wants to
hear but I think it does just show you
that um in terms of some of the things
that GMB are arguing for and obviously
Stephen says you're balancing different
interests
um it is an important thing in this
debate on green going forward because if
you step back we've just come from a
weekend of quite strange briefings in
the Sundays
um about you know where the kirstana
said that he hates Tree Huggers and
meeting on the shadow cabinet and social
you know actually he didn't say that but
if you take a step back from all the
noise what it points to is this ongoing
conversation which is about how much you
prioritize green over economy and how
you link them
um and to therefore if you think back to
the days of lush's Labor conference then
there is a debate about whether to have
a green Rose and they kept it red I
think we're a long way from that point
now
yeah I mean I think Kate is exactly
right then look but candidly
um
I think it is unlikely to put it mildly
than Kirsten said I hate treehuggers
well what's interesting about that route
is that in some ways that
that rather fiery quote you could tell
them it was a relief for labor front
Ventures because they could say well I
was in that meeting and he didn't say
that what none of them dispute is the
tone of the argument in the labor party
about you know to what extent is is
their green plan a is it a way of like
making sure they don't lose loads to the
left be modernizing the economy uh or is
it uh you know Green jobs jobs of the
future you know like
jobs to the boys kind of thing and
ultimately that tension within the later
party is not going to be resolved in an
election and it's going to be one of the
running subplots uh if I think seems
overwhelmingly likely we get a labor
Government after the next election and
then final point I want to ask Katie uh
you mentioned earlier the Tories uh
they've obviously not been shy
historically about trying to exploit uh
Labor's links with the trade unions I
mean given that the trade unions seem to
have not so much the kind of Union
Barons of say Le McCluskey's day et
cetera how will the Tories try to
exploit that coming up to the next
year's election but you can see it this
week when you had to unite vote and of
course you know shows to stay Affiliated
overwhelmingly but there's quotes um
because she had the general secretary
saying now more than ever is the time we
should stay Affiliated because building
up to the elections where we have the
most influence and therefore Greg hands
party chairman coming out and saying you
know as you would expect this is the
same old
um and try to make that attack line do I
think think it's so effective at the
moment I think that Kirsten is trying to
ultimately strike quite a delicate
balance in terms of there is a
preference in the leader's office that
these begins stay Affiliated I think
that as much as sometimes Kristan wants
to pick a fight with the left of the
party there are some concerns of what it
would say if you actually you know lost
the support of the trade unions full
stop
um but this balance of almost you know
showing some strength I also suggest not
dominating everything it's going to be
important for not allowing the Tories to
attack it we don't know yet what a
victory for the labor party looks like
and of course as soon as you have a
situation where you know a large
majority a small majority depending on
the debates things can change but right
now I think that the Tories are not it's
not as easy for attack for the tourist
attack as it has been in the past
plastic surgery is fast becoming a
highly lucrative business fueled by
social media driving unrealistic beauty
standards Louise Perry writes her ass
cover piece this week that this
unregulated industry is becoming
increasingly dangerous Louise joins me
now
Louise you right in this week's magazine
about why life in plastic might not be
so fantastic uh tell us about why you
decided to write about the recent Trend
in plastic surgery
but I think the interesting thing about
plastic surgery is that it has become
super normal super quickly
in that it's obviously been around in
different manifestations for a long time
but it's historically been either
expensive and B uh for that reason very
much associated with a kind of eccentric
minority maybe extremely rich minority
whereas now you know you can get lip
fillers for 200 pounds or something like
that you can get BOTOX for a similar
kind of sum to the extent that those
interventions which are obviously at the
milder into plastic surgery but they're
not trivial
um are so normal that it's actually
affecting what we think normal faces
look like particularly if you look on
screen any celebrity you care to mention
is going to have had something done so
it does affect I think how we regard how
we regard Beauty
um in a way that's clearly trickling
down to teenagers in particular which
ends up being a focus of the piece yes
and in this week's magazine I think you
achieve a journalistic first by guessing
the phrase Brazilian butt lift into the
magazine thank you very much explain to
our readers what a BBL is and why so
many people are getting them uh it is a
procedure where you basically remove fat
from um you kill two birds with one
stone so you remove thatch in some part
of the body where you don't want it and
you put it into your bum
um it's quite dangerous procedure
because you really mustn't
um inject the fat into an artery right
that's really dangerous and actually the
BBL is considered to have one of the
most is one of the most dangerous
cosmetic interventions that you can have
worldwide
um it's also massively increasing in
popularity and the big destination for
UK women to go and get a BBL is uh
turkey
and sometimes they're having cases of
women who go and get a BBL overseas in
you know areas where maybe the industry
is less more regulated and ends up
coming back to the UK having had some
horrible outcome which the NHS then has
to has to fix so it's quite a
um it's a significantly more serious
thing to consider doing than getting a
bit of Botox but it's all on a Continuum
and what's driving in this trend
I honestly think of what drives it is
just that when these new when this new
tech comes on the market you know it's
initially what typically happens is it
comes on the market it's very expensive
it's only adopted by
the super wealthy celebrities whatever
um they show off the results on
Instagram and it kind of filters down
the food chain and then it becomes
cheaper and more normal I think it's
actually one of those Industries where
it's the tech that drives it and they
can hire them just rely on infinite
demands because
um who doesn't want to be beautiful you
know who's like this is the thing like
there's so much data showing that
actually better looking people have
better life experiences in every way you
know they earn more they attract more
attractive Partners like people like
them all there's an incredible level of
inequality actually based on beauty
which we don't really talk about
although locism is an expression that
some people use um in academic
discussion of this so you know based on
that is it crazy to want to spend
however much money you can on looking
better nothing probably not to the
certain sanity behind it are reasoning
behind yeah yeah I think so and in terms
of one views of beauty are and sort of
the cultural interpretations of that you
are really interesting
um bit in the piece we talk about and
Kim Kardashian and how that's changing
Nature's Beauty as well and it seems in
some ways that you sort of get these
kind of plastic surgery from different
bits around the world so you have the
Brazilian butt lift but you also have
South Korean noses as well
yeah we've had a very interesting kind
of uh globalization push within beauty
within Beauty Norms
um and um employ argument in the piece
is that Kim Kardashian and the other
Kardashians that you know that the clan
are obviously very um influential group
of women
um
they deny having had lots of
intervention let's be clear
um you know for the purposes of the tape
but
um I think it's clear that they have had
some work done and like Kylie Jenner for
instance you can buy the Kylie Jenner
package
um at many aesthetic clinics around the
country where you get injections in all
different parts of your face and
um Kim denies having had any kind of
injections in her bum but anyway we can
we can um allow the listeners to decide
for themselves point is that the
aesthetic that they have adopted is an
interestingly kind of ethically
ambiguous one because they have you know
the big bums that we maybe associate
with West African women but then they
have the small noses you're more
commonly found on European women and
then they have like amazing long hair
with extensions that normally you'd only
see on South Asian women so they've kind
of taken some of the most beautiful
features of women from different parts
of the world and artificially
you know put them in the same figure who
then obviously is considered to be a
sort of super super normal stimulus like
the most beautiful woman you can imagine
is basically it's basically Kim
Kardashian and that look can really only
be achieved artificially so I call it
the Coca-Cola of beauty and then it's
like taking all the most delicious
possible elements and putting it into
this one
consumable and so telling I think a lot
about the modern beauty industry is how
it markets itself as accessible the sort
of classless but as the sort of
implication of your piece is that
there's big money involved in trying to
make yourself achieve this Coca-Cola
look
yeah yeah and the the Emerging Market
um is the middle classes is is you know
women who are maybe and some men as well
though it's mostly women who are doing
this who are earning you know 40 50k
like that's the kind of demographic that
are now starting to to adopt some of
these procedures which were previously
The Preserve of the Rich and
increasingly young women as well you
know like baby Botox I've never even
heard that expression but that's Botox
that you start getting in maybe when
you're 30 as a way of preventing the
wrinkles and yeah that's that's a
extremely accessible we could say
ubiquitous is with another way of
putting it isn't he also mentioned I
mean you mentioned the the Kardashians
and obviously they're now in their
mid-40s so it's also a case of you know
not just people in their 30s getting it
but 40s and 50s as well I mean as you
said earlier but you think that most uh
women who are you know famous in their
50s or so you say on television will
have had to have some kind of surgery or
something to help with that we had his
beloved shot on a teaming four saying
that her looks are a key part of her job
and frankly you know BBC presented to
the Past said they wouldn't be put on TV
unless they're going to be looking a
certain way so it's also about women
getting older as well isn't it yeah and
they're not wrong you know you can't I
don't feel like one can blame individual
women for making completely irrational
decisions on the basis of you know if
you want to sustain a TV career or
whatever it is probably a good idea to
get BOTOX
um and that's I think one of the things
that's so pernicious about this that
what we think say a 50 year old woman
looks like is really skewed by the fact
that the 50 year old women we've seen on
magazines and on the TV
actually look about 35 right and and
even someone you know like Meryl Streep
is looking absolutely incredible for a
woman in her 70s you know like in a way
that you would I think never
I have no idea how much work she's done
but you would never see that
historically so we are moving into a
sort of different era we have this
almost cyborg Beauty which is achieved
through technology do you think there's
enough of a debate around this because
it seems to me perhaps that when it
comes to plastic surgery people don't
want to intrude about people's looks Etc
but also maybe perhaps there's a stigma
to do with politicians say for instance
in terms of you know the regulation
around all this is there enough of that
kind of debate going on I mean I think
that there's a very strong argument for
regulating the more dangerous stuff the
BBL for instance is I think probably too
dangerous really
um although of course one of the
problems is that we might regulate it
Heavenly in the UK but it's hard to stop
people from going overseas and getting
it done more cheaply So It's Tricky
um
You Can't Ban Botox though realistically
you know I I it's
the I think that if we're going to try
and intervene at any point you know and
my advice to any readers who are anxious
about their teenage girls for instance
being
um becoming obsessed with this stuff is
probably through trying to restrict
teenagers using social media because we
know that a really big way that this is
filtering through the culture is through
social media where you know hashtag
Barbie nose job on Tick Tock because
it's incredibly popular there's this
trend on Tick Tock which I wasn't aware
of before writing this piece for girls
to do these like before and after
um videos on Tick Tock and they just go
wild like millions and millions of likes
which is strange for me because I
thought this shows how old I am I
thought that you were supposed to kind
of keep it secret if you'd had work done
whereas it seems that actually now for
Zoomers
boasting about the work you've had done
is considered fine and that obviously
encourages other girls to do the same
and a lot of plastic surgeons are
advertising their their clinics on
social media you know click the link in
BIO and you can get this done yourself
and it's also packs a case as well that
you know in the early noughties there's
a certain stereotype of the kind of
women who'd be getting plastic surgery
Etc do you think that with the kind of
cultural change as well it's you know it
people from different classes Etc are
going to be seen much more of it and
it's a Trends and they're going to
continue
I think probably yeah I mean we still
you know think of Madonna for instance
who's had clearly had a lot of work done
and she's had a lot of fun made out of
her for that
um I think that there's still a view
that having too much is is worthy of
derision you've got to feel sorry about
some of these older female celebrities
who they have too much work done they
get made fun of if they don't have any
work done they lose their livelihoods
right so they've got a real tight Trip
To Tread which is really difficult and
yeah unfortunately I don't think that we
are likely to see this going
in any other direction than just
continued escalation it's funny when I
talk to some older women for instance
who can recall a period where having
even less spending even less on your
appearance was considered normal you
know things like it didn't apparently
used to be Colin for older women to dye
their hair it used to be much more
common to just gradually become gray and
be natural whereas I think now dyeing
your hair is completely normal and it's
actually quite rare to see women turning
gray at the point that they naturally
would turn gray
um maybe we're going to have the same
things with having having forehead
wrinkles so the Bali film which is
coming out in the coming weeks uh might
not just be a fantasy anymore but much
more of closer to reality for some women
ask about men getting past the surgery
as well you mentioned it it's less than
10 I think also getting that amount but
do you think this is going to be the
kind of next thing as well with much
more focus on kind of male grooming Etc
and learn being talked about social
media this can become the next big thing
yeah I mean men are getting things done
like um men do you get BOTOX done men
can get things like jawline fillers to
make your jaw look stronger you get like
whatever the acid they insert onto your
skin so there are sort of male specific
work that you can get done
um I think that we should always expect
women to be more interested in this and
for them to make up most of the market I
think the simple reason that beauty
female Beauty has always had this
enormous kind of social status
I think the counterpart to that for men
is actually looking men looking Rich
yeah right men's having expensive suits
and fancy cars and you know that sort of
the gendered counterpart and finally I
mean there's an iron there isn't there
between all the focus on body positivity
when actually it's very kind of
prescriptive in terms of what women and
men should look like into what their
look should be and having all this kind
of artificial treatment
you can fold that in quite nicely though
can't you into a sort of alternative
narrative or actually going and getting
work done is like living your truth you
know your expression of whatever you
want your body to be there's a certain
sort of I don't know self-fashioning
that you can achieve through aesthetic
treatments which in a way actually fits
quite well with that style of of
um sort of gender politics
um I think it's a coherent but it seems
as though lots of the the girls on Tick
Tock are quite happy to pursue it quite
cynical self-justifications wow who can
blame them to be honest who complain
them thank you very much
and finally this summer showing
Britain's true love of tabloid gossip
first there was Phillip Schofield then
just last week George Osborne Poisoned
Pen email and now the BBC Scandal is on
the front page of most national
newspapers but what's behind Britain's
relationship with gossip how far back
does it stretch in our history with me
to discuss is the Regency historian an
author Alice loxton
now Alice it's been a big week for uh
Gossip and the Press with these stories
about George Osborne's poison pen letter
the allegations around what's happening
with the BBC at the moment
um but this is something that we've have
a sort of natural tendency towards don't
we well we do indeed I mean I've been
looking a lot recently at the satires or
the print shops of the 18th century and
the way that gossip was elevated I think
by these print shops
um really puts the the Tabloid
journalism of today to shame so I think
you know the era of James gilray and
Thomas roninson and Isaac Crookshank and
all of those people who were who are
basically
um just visualizing the the Chit Chat
and the the kind of anecdotes that were
flying through Westminster they were
kind of real powerful force in in
society at the end of the 18th century
and obviously it's spectator we have
coffee house which is our blog and Nod
to that there'll be coffee houses of
those era and all the gossip that was
exchanged there
um and this sort of tradition has echoed
down the century hasn't it where people
sort of gathered to meet and there's
something about Westminster life where
those surrounding notes are swapped and
shared right yeah I mean coffee houses
were a really exciting thing um they're
really capable for in the 18th century I
think and they were this place where
people were supposed to come along and
just you know disseminate ideas and
discuss all you know all kinds of people
would be gathering there
um and there were all sorts of rules
about it that would really encourage
discussion and debate and they'd have
all of the the prints that were being
produced they'd have lots of the uh the
the the weekly papers and magazines
sorts of things coming out so it was a
real place for for discussion and debate
um and saw a place that you'd love to
hang out James in your spare time but
yeah and I think you know the it's it's
the kind of the the um essence of that
probably exists in spectator and the way
that it's always this kind of Hub of
debate and that sort of thing and then
your excellent spectator's life piece
and utilize about a French visitor to
one of these coffee houses and explain
me is there something kind of unique to
perhaps London of that era or the Brits
in terms of things like you know our
print tradition our kind of culture is
there something uniquely British about
gossip well um in the late 18th century
when there were this kind of Pinnacle of
satire and print shops this was
something which was pretty pretty
powerful it was a pretty powerful force
in politics it's shaped politics quite
profoundly in lots of ways to shape
Society in all sorts of different ways
shaped the way that we make jokes shaped
the way that people had conversations
and it was something which was quite
specific and unique to London perhaps
because of the the artists who happened
to be working here
um but also there was a kind of freedom
of discussion
um people were it was much more relaxed
about what you could say you know you
could criticize the king in a print and
his Palace would be just nearby and and
foreign visitors would come to London
and they'd be shocked that you could
criticize somebody so
um you know so so blatantly and you
weren't allowed to do this in other
countries in France and in other places
so it was it was a kind of real unique
thing that we had here
um and and you know people across the
continent would would um would they
loved they loved hearing about I mean
the Germans loved hearing there was this
entire magazine called one in Paris it
was all about kind of the London print
shops and they loved hearing all the
gossip of the print shops and they were
just kind of fascinated by how people
could get away with this really so
partly because of the the Britain's kind
of political history as it were post
English Civil War and the kind of
Enlightenment and the change of the 18th
century Etc that was part of the reason
also technological change as well which
made the dissemination of these kind of
gossip and pamphlets possible yeah I
mean I think in the late 18th century
almost perhaps you know George the third
daughter Paul they're all being
criticizing this like really blatant way
but perhaps they thought you know
putting these prints out in the print
shop Windows perhaps this was a way for
people to air their grievances that
wasn't really making much difference you
know it's almost like kind of like
release that I think was quite healthy
um because you know they did collect
themselves like Prince George's
collecting them yeah
um we know that Charles James Fox would
you know there's anecdotes of him going
to Hannah Humphrey's print shop there's
a great print shop
um you know she was they were all based
kind of Piccadilly James's secondary and
he would go in and he would talk to him
and you know he was so charming and she
was Charmed by childhood and then he
could see all these satires of him being
you know like really quite brutal and he
was like oh oh well this is hungry I
better have one and then he went on his
way laughing or something like that you
know there's like all these kind of
anecdotes of them kind of just accepting
it and and lots of the politicians were
very keen to be in them so George
canning when he is on his way up he
makes a huge effort to be featured in
gilray print he like tries to
orchestrate all of these
um these meetings with him he's got a
mutual friend and he's like please just
make introduce me to gilray but don't
make it look like I've been asked to
introduce so he'll be like
um yeah and so what they did he gave he
was given this kind of package to
deliver to gilray's house
um and then he was like well look while
you're there you can try and like get
get away in
um it didn't quite work but eventually
canning does get in and he must have
been delighted when he the first print
that he saw when he is featured in
Gilroy print he is it's like this kind
of nightmarish scene of the French
Revolution as if it happened in London
and canning it's like all the clubs you
know whites club and all this like pits
it's like disasters struck London and
canning's hanging from a Lamppost but
you know I'm sure that he was actually
delighted to be featured because it was
a real marker of being part of the
political bubble but what I really also
like is how you know those kind of
Trends have Echo Through the Ages and
continued to other line because
obviously we were just discussing before
with him on there George Osborne loves
gilray cartoon oh yeah yeah well um
George Osborne
had a pretty Niche gilray event a couple
of years ago
outside
San jacadilly which is which is the big
church on pigtaily
um there is a stone which is a gilray
stone um in the ground and it's it's
kind of you know this is very slow but
it is happening a kind of gilray kind of
momentum they're a Revival that I'm
trying to get going um but that was
before I wrote the book but um he he was
invited as the person to unveil the
stone it was about 30 40 people kind of
standing in a circle around it's quite
like low-key event all the gilray
enthusiasts which are not there's not
that many of them both of them um yeah
yeah
and yeah it was like uni Jacko the floor
and then he like took it off and then
everyone was like because I don't know
it was quite low-key the whole thing but
um yeah he was he was obviously invited
because he has both been satirized but
also commissioned a lot of Santa by
being in the papes and stuff
um but he he was telling me how you know
he he would visit he's visited people's
um quite senior people's Like Houses in
the conservative party and you know you
go into their house in like in the the
entrance hall is just like covered in
all of The Sapphires of themselves and
I'm sure other people have seen that
from other people as well so people do
like being featured I think Ted Heath's
house is basically a sort of a memorial
to himself and bundles yeah yeah there's
just picture them everywhere you back
yourself and what else should I call
this as well as a you know obviously
writing so much about the past and sort
of the history of gossip and satiety in
centuries you yourself obviously had a
stint ad on the times diary as well and
so dealing with the gossip of today and
so how do you think it's changed from
your perspective as a direct early 2020s
compared to uh what it'd been like a few
centuries ago
um yeah that's a good question so I yeah
I've been working I've done a bit of the
Diary stuff um it's quite tricky I find
it quite trick I finally talk about like
you know trying to get the gossip and
stuff quite tricky because you have to
be quite you have to be I don't know it
feels like I don't even know where the
line is between are we being friends or
is this like work but um I think
um well I I guess what the the what I
find so exciting about the prince of the
late 18th century in gilray is that
obviously case obviously in the past
everything's much much slower you know
news is much lower but I do think we
have that that kind of like immediacy
that you can a sort of immediacy that we
have today in the prince of the 18th
century because you know there'll be a
rumor that would come out in London and
then James gilray would Scurry back make
this print within 24 hours and it would
be on the print the window and it was
that kind of like immediacy like
breaking news kind of kind of story that
you do get with gossip circuling around
Westminster today you know that email
that was sent around about George
Osborne
um so I guess the I think compared to
other forms of people receiving the news
in the past
um the London printmakers are very very
similar to all they have that they have
a sense of the kind of Thrill of the
breaking news story the last thing was
the quality of satire and gossip better
now back then oh back then for sure for
sure and I think if if Gilroy I think
the the kind of treatment that
politicians get today is quite
team I think hey yeah I think so I think
if Gilroy was around today and we think
about some of the scandals that are
happening they would absolutely tear
into to some of these politicians I
think in a way that perhaps people
criticize them quite openly now but not
in a kind of really brilliant creative
witty
um really acerbic way original yeah yeah
I think I mean the reason I love these
These Guys these like artists Jet gilray
and Ronson is okay it's like interesting
political history but I think they're
like really brilliant creatives you know
absolutely top-notch creatives if you
want to get like a a really impressive
marketing campaign today you get someone
like girl writing because he could like
really like knew how to kind of work
images and turn things in a clever way
um you know and you look at these images
and they're still really weird and
they're still really like they stay with
you and we've seen you know everything
that's ever been created from Hollywood
or CGI or like Photoshop and even all of
that at gilray's images are really
striking and if you think that they're
still striking today they must have been
like incredibly powerful in the 1790s
which is why our brilliant cartoonist
mortal Moreland still references gilray
in his works like the one of the Boris
and Carrie and Dom The Haunting yeah uh
which was uh well you've yeah even
you've used the plum pudding on your
cover many many times so because they
echo down the ages so perhaps it would
be could see the men of those era will
still recognize the images today thank
you very much
that's it for watching please remember
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
join us again same time next week
[Music]